comment alors si les particuliers sont
inquiets les entreprises aussi le medef
vient même de créer une cellule de
veille pour leur transmettre toutes les
informations
les grands groupes ont déjà commencé à
se préparer et à faire face à une
éventuelle pandémie reportage patricia
et ça ça me guide dans ces deux pièces
l'aéroport d'orly store ce qu'on appelle
ici des munitions comme si on
s'attendait à devoir mener une guerre
contre la grippe aviaire dans les
cartons
plus de cent cinquante mille masques
40000 dans et 4000 combinaison toute en
équipements pour lutter contre une
éventuelle pandémie et par crainte de
pillages la porte a même été blainville
ce sera notre blogueur parce que je
pense qu'il faudra faire une procédure
pour que nos employés en est il faudra
basé notre distribution sur 12 semaines
notre plan de pandémie est basé sur 12
semaines pour tenir ici les voyageurs
viennent du monde entier alors à orly
comme dans tous les aéroports certains
salariés sont inquiets ils se sentent
même en première ligne en cas de
pandémie mais ils n'ont pas été
autorisés à parler déjà échaudée par
l'épidémie de frace la direction et le
service médical ont pris les devants à
coude affiches et de mails internes
ils veulent responsabiliser le personnel
et il n'y a pas que les aéroports de
paris qui s'en préoccuper dans cette
salle une quarantaine de chefs
d'entreprises françaises
la plupart doivent gérer des filiales à
l'étranger et notamment en asie
ils sont venus écouter les
recommandations d'international sos une
société de conseils en matière de
gestion des risques
car au delà du défi sanitaire il s'agit
de maintenir l'activité économique et
industriel je dirais que l'état d'esprit
est en effet considéré les ce risque de
pandémie comme un risque industriel sur
lequel il faut mettre en place une
prévention dès maintenant certaines
entreprises en effet en mis en place des
protocoles extrêmement opérationnel pour
gérer au mieux la gestion
tristan d'un point de vue ils viennent
distribution de médicaments ou solistes
des voyages des collaborateurs l'enjeu
est de taille selon des analystes une
pandémie de grippe aviaire aurait des
répercussions sur l'économie mondiale
comparable à la grande dépression des
années 30